[Music]
it's election day while it's unclear
which races Republicans and Democrats
will win it could be days perhaps even
longer before we know the final midterm
results what is certain is that this
election looks different for voters
across the U.S there are many laws in
many states that voters are going to be
having to navigate for the first time
this year in the wake of the contentious
2020 election
rules have changed and more observers
have been deployed here's a look at how
the presidential election made a lasting
impact and why some people are concerned
that the changes we see this year from
voting regulations and voting methods to
poll Watchers could affect voter turnout
and the future of our elections
at least 40 states have passed laws in
the last two years that either tighten
voting rules or expand voting access
according to nyu's Brennan Center for
justice a public policy think tank that
tracks election legislation if we're
talking about whether it's become harder
or easier to vote and I really think it
depends on where a voter happens to live
since 2020 28 states have passed
measures that would make it easier for
eligible Americans to register stay on
the rolls or vote
in Vermont all registered voters will be
mailed a ballot for the November
presidential and midterm elections under
a law passed in 2021
and in Kentucky a new law established
three days of early in-person voting
expansive voting laws are recognition by
legislators that more access means a
more full fair and engaged democracy
20 states have passed laws that the
Brennan Center classifies as restrictive
which can include measures that shorten
Windows to apply for a mail ballot
limit the availability of ballot drop
boxes impose stricter signature
requirements or impose stricter voter ID
requirements
among these are Arizona's HB 2492 law
which established a proof of citizenship
requirement for voter registration and
Georgia's SB 202 which requires voters
to provide an approved type of ID like a
driver's license or voter identification
card when requesting and returning an
absentee ballot
Republicans say the changes were needed
to restore confidence among voters in
the Integrity of Elections while
Democrats believe the law is meant to
depress minority turnout and that former
president Donald Trump and his
supporters corroded faith in the process
no evidence of widespread fraud has been
found in the 2020 election but the
unsubstantiated claims have motivated
some people to get involved
while poll watching is a common feature
where people monitor ballot casting and
Counting for possible rule violations
there are concerns that highly partisan
volunteers could try to intimidate
voters this year one of the features of
our election system is this this
transparency the ability for people to
watch and observe but it also does
create a vulnerability if a bad actor
Gets In Trey Grayson oversaw two
presidential elections and two midterm
elections as Kentucky's Secretary of
State we have to make sure that the
observers aren't intimidating voters or
doing something that they shouldn't be
doing during that observation process
the RNC says it has recruited over 123
000 poll workers and poll Watchers in
primary General and special elections
this cycle the DNC said state-level
Democratic parties take the lead on
recruiting poll Watchers it all comes
back to balancing the transparency of
our system with not wanting folks to be
intimidated we don't want voters to feel
like somebody's watching or will do
something to them and that causes them
to not vote more than 43 million ballots
have been cast as of November 7th and
there are signs that this year's
elections could meet or possibly exceed
2018's midterm turnout it'll take until
well after the election when most or all
mail-in ballots have been counted before
we get a full picture of voter
participation we'll find out if that's
just a sign of people shifting their
voting preference or a sign of high
overall turnout
a recent Wall Street Journal poll shows
voter enthusiasm is high with 81 percent
of respondents saying they definitely
will vote this year and eight percent
saying they already have I'm going to be
looking for some of these new laws that
we're seeing in States how they work how
they impact turnout and also the the
poll Watcher issue and then finally I
want to see the results of some of these
election administrators Secretary of
States and a few Governors that appoint
secretaries because that could have a
tremendous impact on our the future of
our elections